black lives matter demonstrations broke
out over the summer after the killing of
george floyd
an unknown black man killed in police
custody all this week we're examining
what changes metro police have made and
what still needs to be done
bianca holman tells us how a local
chapter of the black police officers
association
is influencing the force las vegas
chapter has become like
the chapter when it comes to events and
a lot of other states they look up to us
and to see what we're doing this is the
willie smoot
award one of several the las vegas
chapter of the black police officers
association bpoa
has won through the years because of
their events like back to school fairs
holiday programs and most recently drive
through food banks
regina coward-holman is the local
chapter president and was a metro
officer for more than 20 years
service is over everything because if
you can't serve
you're not going to be effective coward
holmen and current officer adrian hunt
realize their race and background
influences the job that's our job we
failed is just to bridge the community
you know that we grew up in and to show
them hey
you know that we're here you know and
we're regular people just like you guys
founded in 1972 the bpoa's mission is to
be the conscious of the criminal justice
system
advocate for officers of color and
improve the quality of life in the black
community
and in the black community the excessive
use of force by police is a recurring
issue
the death of george floyd an unarmed
black man killed in police custody
and the death of brianna taylor
triggered protests around the country
our national chair she was on every talk
show that she could possibly get on to
get the message out and the message was
about
being accountable black men are twice as
likely to die
in an interaction with police than white
men that's according to a report in the
american journal of public health in
addition
black people make up only 7 percent of
metro's police force
and 10 percent of the entire staff
including civilians officer hunt says
that's a cause for concern my thing is
to always push and push
into you know to get more people who
look like me
to join the department metro has a
multicultural advisory council that
provides feedback to the sheriff monthly
however coward holmen says black
officers should be at the table with
leadership more often
and help train the department when it
comes to racial issues she says frequent
cultural awareness classes can save
lives
who better to teach these classes than
the people who work for you
who actually know both sides of the
story howard holman says tension
embedded in our country's history
can only be healed by working together
we've been
in this community pounding the sand for
20 years but for the last eight years
we've been pounding it hard because we
have to make a change
and the department can't do it by
themselves reporting bianca holman
8 news now